Daniel Michael Gallagher coupable
d'homicide volontaire son préméditation
vous avez préparé une déclaration pour
notre commission il n'y a pas eu un jour
depuis que je suis là où je n'ai pas
pensé à Alexandra forest parce que j'ai
besoin de comprendre ce que j'ai fait
comment elle est morte et pourquoi
il était quelqu'un d'autre je te dirai
de faire supérieur pourquoi elle en
particulier
[Musique]
tu devrais rester je n'ai jamais pensé
que c'est ce qu'on faisait c'est quoi là
je croyais que j'avais réglé le problème
et cette maladie chez moi
si tu dis à quelqu'un d'arrêter de
t'appeler et qu'elle a 20e fois tu
décroches tout ce que tu lui auras
appris c'est qu'il faut 20 à peine pour
te faire réagir il faut que je te dise
quelque chose baisse j'ai choisi de
perdre le contrôle
je crois que c'est terminé entre nous
je refuse d'être ignoré dan
je n'ai pas tué cette femme et je vais
pouvoir le prouver
[Musique]